- In this one brief moment
and in this challenging
time when our government
is pushing us backward,
at a time when the truth is disposable
and deceit is used as a strategic weapon,
when the echoes of past injustices linger
just beneath the surface,
waiting to burst forth like a broken dam,
we need courage not just from politicians,
but from ordinary
Americans in every corner
of this land and everywhere in between.
Our democracy is counting
on each and every one of you
and in your countless
acts of selfless courage
to do your part.
You see, when millions of
us do just our small part
at the same time, there
is no mountain too high,
no task too daunting, no dream too big.
So to every American listening,
you may not be the
tallest or the strongest
or the best looking or the richest
or the fastest or the smartest
or the most well-collected.
You may look different, love different,
you may pray different.
It is of no moment nor matter.
We must all choose to
find a way or make one
because this is our America.